yeah so canadian
shadow mate
let's start with the same moves
three d4 develop fast and see
the middle game positions how they
handle it
knight hd4 next and g3 maybe
okay
black should know what he's doing in
this lines
because if white just controls h1 a8 the
diagonal and the d-bone it becomes like
kind of a weakness
long term it's a problem for black so
they should do something about it
and let's see what he does here after g3
he probably doesn't know the line that
well
okay let's see okay d5 possible but then
can even go this maybe
yeah now i don't want to let him castle
um how can i actually keep this kind of
stuff going
i hope i'm not losing the queen
somewhere nice three can i go queen b4
yeah i can assign queen b4
okay let's castle short
and pretend we know what we're doing
i have no idea what i'm doing here but
uh
anyway some kind of tricks are there so
queen c2 maybe some bishop b2 afterwards
if let's take one a5 song bishop b2
ng7 will be hanging and then items
history of course
okay d4
it's interesting d4
um i haven't seen d4 but
[Music]
can i go with three let's say
he cannot go c5 anyway because i'll take
the a8
so he should do something else what
exactly
when a6 maybe
possibly
yeah and i cannot go bishop c5 there
because of queen c4
bishop d492
queen a6 is maybe the tricky move but i
mean i can go maybe queen b3 as well
trying to play for queen b4
it seems that i'm having a good position
anyway but um
certainly with engines here as black
it's possible to put a lot of
problems to white to pose some problems
to white
but but it's nice to have these two
bishops just cutting the entire board
more or less
a3f8 and all that very dangerous for
black
okay now after queen takes d4 i will
play bishop b2 the knight is trapped
oh i mean so traps he can go queen a5
still but
this is like trapped more or less should
the d6 pawn to c5
yeah it's winning okay